is a waste of time
you know i'm feeling like i'm in a box
here so
i'm noticing a lot of people
but you see because you can't do the
second one
a little bit there's a bit more space
here
same technique a little more space so
when i come here
so what i'd like you to do is put
yourself under a little bit of pressure
you just stick to slightly slowly
him here
now i'm taking this little piece from
the yonko
but you know i said he comes with my
hand and i move it watch this hand as it
comes down
i leave it there but
it it already made the shape i just
followed him down
so what gives they saying i could
redirect their power so without him
knowing i'm gonna actually
redirect
you
no
[Music]
whether you got it or not
i'm behind him always
so
an easy passage
[Music]
that's the strongest